hi there Steve coffin here today I want
to answer a question that I got here on
my youtube channel and it basically is
about how do I get past that
intermediate level person here remove n
which is the username on my youtube
channel says how do you get past the
intermediate wall I'm at a point with
French where I understand native
speakers I'm able to speak about
different topics but sometimes struggle
to say things a certain way and express
myself all right let's talk about that
for a second here first of all if you
enjoy these podcasts or at least videos
please subscribe to my channel my answer
to a remove n is congratulations you
have achieved a lot I love it when I get
to that level in a language where I
understand native speakers wow that's
big that's huge many I think that's the
first step comprehension that's the base
from which other things develop that's
where you gotta get to through input and
listening and reading and speaking and
listening and reading again to where you
can understand native speakers able to
speak about different topics but
sometimes struggle well of course you
sometimes struggle and as you continue
to speak and interact with native
speakers you gradually get better but
you've now got that grip on the language
well you can enjoy things in the
language you can go out with people in
French you can watch movie you can read
books you can enjoy interesting things
in the language acquire knowledge you
know pursue your interests and all the
while as you're doing these things and
and you should try not to be
self-conscious about about your skills
about the things you aren't able to do
just be confident that in enjoying the
language and using it and interacting
with the language you're going to get
better and and I would say that you're
not at an intermediate level you're not
at the intermediate while you're at a at
a high intermediate level of starting to
approach advanced because a lot of
people don't get past the beginner level
they don't get to a level where they can
understand
and a lot of what native speakers say
and I have in the past compared language
learning to an upside down hockey stick
I don't have a hockey stick here but if
you can imagine a hockey stick with the
blade if you turn it upside down you've
got this first period in language
learning which is quite steep but where
we have this sense that we're where all
of a sudden able to understand some
things in the language we're able to say
some things in the language there's this
feeling of discovery and and wow look at
me I can fly I can swim I can ride my
bicycle I can do things that I wasn't
able to do before
but then pretty soon we hit that flatter
longer the shaft of the hockey stick and
it's a long long journey it's a long
journey of acquiring words and gradually
increasing our comprehension increasing
our ability to do things in fact
increasing our vocabulary that's what it
basically boils down to and that's a
constant rise and you never quite feel
that you're as good as you would like to
be in all of my languages all of the
languages that I speak I would like to
be better if I had time if I weren't
trying to work on a new language I would
go back in and improve in French in
Japanese in Mandarin in Spanish in
German in the languages that I already
speak to some degree you're never going
to be a hundred percent you know as good
in your language you're learning as you
are in your own language so I think it's
very important and I say this all the
time
I wherever you are on this hockey stick
even if you're on that first sort of
steep portion where the language is
still confusing and you listen and still
don't understand but you're struggling
to get up to that the first sort of
ledge or if you're on that long long
road of gradually improving wherever you
are you should say look at me I'm good I
can do stuff in the language that I
couldn't do before and all I have to do
is to continue and enjoy the process
find interesting things to listen to an
focus on that enjoyment rather than
trying to second-guess yourself gee I'm
not as good as I'd like to be forget all
of that you will there's always this
element of uncertainty not quite as sure
of yourself and and self-doubt and stuff
like that forget it enjoy it so that's
my advice how do you overcome the
intermediate wall keep going it's a good
place to be
bye for now
[Music]